hi everybody I am Aaron Paul and I am
here to answer fan questions while
playing with cats where are the cats
where the cat hey also do you have dogs
oh no bring out the kiddies oh my god
[Music]
beautiful kitty it's hard to not say
this I mean you know I think I think I
mean I think breaking bad
you know Breaking Bad was a
life-changing experience for me playing
Jesse Pinkman was a once-in-a-lifetime
role and it led me to all these kitties
so you know yeah it's the best oh my god
they'd be best friends of course hey you
are so cute
Mike would be amazing I mean Gustavo
Fring getting blown up Tuco be good to
be honest I think my upcoming character
on Wes world I may relate to the most I
just wrapped 9 a.m. this morning I have
not slept it is now six almost 6:30 feel
like I'm on drugs in a bad way I am
going to steal at least half of these
kitties not all because that would be
too much what does 3 make me a cat
person no kinda more than two just one
actually makes you at peppers it pays
well uh if you can get a job you get to
play with cats during interviews oh my
god you're so cute
is that why has a pink spot on its here
is it born that way I know
I am loving sci-fi I've always loved
sci-fi to watch that's my favorite genre
I think but to dive into Westworld
doing Syfy's is incredibly ambitious my
god it's such a brutal show to shoot
feel so blessed to be a part of it I
like horror but I don't like doing
horror you know I've done one horror
movie and it was not fun just blood all
over chicken and biscuits god there's a
lot you know what to be on its first day
was just really incredible seeing my
Breaking Bad family the crew so many
people from the crew of the pilot was
there sort of walking on on set I think
that was the greatest memory
legend you know I love Brian so much he
bought me lunch and the cast lunch he is
I said that so many times before he's
the most professional / immature person
I've ever met in my life but in the most
Oh
that's holy they have sharp claws
I love cat look I love cats this one
just hit on me it didn't it just farted
though seriously that was not that was
not me that's an obvious cat fart hey
you know I want to do a shout out to
Best Friends Animal Society for
providing these beautiful kittens if
anyone wants to adopt a kitten and give
one of these little guys a home you can
go to bestfriends dot org kittens for
everybody Cheers